The Bulletin of Atomic Scientists say
that the earth is now closer to doomsday
than ever before that's right they've
been tracking this stuff for a while and
they basically use like a clock to say
how close we are to pretty much
destroying ourselves or the earth just
destroying us or some compilation
thereof we've got some info for you so
the u.s. advocacy group founded by the
creators of the atomic bomb move their
famous doomsday clock ahead two minutes
it said that the world is now three
minutes from a catastrophic midnight
instead of five minutes so let's just
look at the timeline for a second here
so in case it isn't clear exactly what's
happening here basically they're taking
our day is sort of the timeline for
Humanity and then they're factoring in
all these different things between
global warming and nuclear weapons and
other political geopolitical things and
saying how close we are to destroying
ourselves or you know some sort of
either man-made catastrophe or something
with the earth getting rid of us so 1984
they said we were three minutes away to
midnight now that was in the heat of the
Cold War so obviously there was a threat
of atomic war all the time 1991 we were
17 minutes so that's seven years later
and then we were further away from
strong ourselves cuz 1991 things were
basically pretty good the Cold War was
gone and the earth seemed to be in a
pretty good state then in 2002 we got
closer to midnight again and this is
shortly after nine eleven obviously and
then as you can see in 2012 we were a
little closer and now into that's
between three minutes to midnight okay
so technically we're not three minutes
away your baby through this video I
promise you but I think these things are
kind of interesting it again we're doing
a bunch of sciency stuff with you guys
so there's something there's some
science behind this and then there's
also like a little I don't know what can
we call this is just kind of fantasies I
mean it's a bit it's a bit arbitrary the
numbers right right well it's like
really like strict algorithm that they
use to come right like this but yeah
obviously after the Cold War when we
started to see nations being involved in
nuclear arms reduction talks
people started to feel a lot safer and I
think the interesting thing is that
historically the Doomsday Clock really
had almost everything to do with nuclear
war but now these scientists are saying
okay nuclear war is still a risk but
global warming is it like an equivalent
risk and so we have to really take that
into account because when we talk about
doomsday and we talked about the end of
humanity we could be wiping ourselves
off the face of the earth because of
climate change yeah do you fear man-made
disasters or just natural disasters more
as our way that we're gonna we're gonna
go down yeah I think I think that we
definitely have the potential to you
know to blow ourselves up um but I in
the article uh Steven Pinker was
referenced who says that we live in the
least violent times ever yeah all of
history but like you know because of the
24-hour news cycle if it bleeds it leads
on you know mainstream media like it's
stokes our amygdala right which fires up
our fight-or-flight so we have the sense
that we're living a really violent times
we're actually not so I'm not really
that concerned but we're also living in
a climate where we don't have to be that
violent overall to see mass destruction
because it only takes one crazy person
with access to very strong weapons and
the farther and farther along we get the
more that we're seeing individuals who
maybe have no right and granted this is
coming from an American who thinks that
we have no right to have nuclear weapons
either um but you know the fire power
has increased exponentially so it takes
a small group of people with a lot of
firepower to do a lot of damage when
historically the firepower was less
intense so more people needed to be
violent right so for example in the Cold
War we had mutual deterrence basically
if we were going to do anything they
were going to blow us up to and now
there's so many smaller actors and the
threat of a dirty bomb exactly North
Korea Iran you know what happens if Isis
gets involved and like those are the
kinds of things where I personally I'm
not like you know staying up at night
but it does worry me because there are
people who because of religious
implications don't have any concept of
kind of shepherding the earth for many
years to come because they literally
think that like the end is nigh I mean
they literally want it they wanted
better they think they're going to
heaven right which is batshit crazy and
so that
like that you really feel exactly that's
what worries me most is when you have
when you have an actor who is not afraid
of the ramifications of their actions
all of a sudden that person with the gun
becomes a lot more dangerous yeah do you
guys think this is why we have to
explore space I mean it seems to me that
at some point here and you could every
sci-fi movie that they go on any
adventure anywhere I mean what was the
one with Matthew McConaughey just a
couple months ago you're selling your
seller I mean this is what you know that
we're gonna travel the cosmos to find
another planet that will sustain life
because we're gonna screw up this whole
thing I mean is this the whole point why
we have to put money I think into NASA
knows that I don't really think that
we're gonna be alive to see the fruition
of those searches but you know I do look
to guys like Richard Branson an Elon
Musk and I'm like these guys have the
right idea because I mean we are on some
kind of trajectory for sure but I you
know I try to remain optimistic you know
I think that um I think everything's
gonna be okay let's remember here we
with you know global climate change
which i think is probably the talking
point of this article specifically it's
less now about nuclear war but with
global climate change we have the
potential and we are actively destroy
not the earth per se but ourselves yeah
the famous boat in it right the Oracle
burner yes is that life will find a way
like the cockroaches probably won't die
off yeah we are killing ourselves off we
are making the climate not habitable for
humankind anymore and that's something
we have to remember is that really the
best way to fo to frame it because when
you say it in that sense like people
think the earth is just gonna explode
but that's really not what's gonna
happen we're just going to change things
to the point where our species the
things that we need to survive the water
we need to drink of the air we need to
breathe etc will not work I wants to say
that we there have been major climactic
events in the past and there have been
mass extinctions and we are gearing up
for one and we are contributing to it
that's the crazy thing we are
exacerbating this well if it happens
then I guess the aliens will come here
and then right men our bones will be
buried deep which will turn into oil
that the aliens
is that has anyone brought that theory
anyway what do you think let us know in
the comments right down below